des médicaments qui prolonge la vie
d'autres qui ralentissent la progression
de la maladie
des diagnostics plus précis la recherche
de pointe sur le cancer de la prostate
connaît des années fastes le progrès est
extraordinaire depuis les crises
dernières années parce qu'on commence un
mieux comprendre les maladies et deux
ans qu'on s'a convaincre la population
et les décideurs
reste un constat qui doit être pris au
sérieux florian jean un patient du
docteur saad qui souffre d'un grave
cancer avec métastases pu en témoigner
les médecins puis qui sait
ils m'ont prolonger le scada il ya deux
ans après notre rechute on lui propose
un traitement expérimental qui agit sur
certains gènes défectueux avec l'oeil a
commencé à faire la recherche au niveau
de l'adn a cherché des des biomarqueurs
dans mon cas il ne trouvait chez l'homme
comme chez la femme
certaines mutations sur les gènes brca1
et 2 prédispose à des formes très
agressive du cancer
c'est un problème qu'on peut maintenant
traités selon une étude à laquelle le
chum a participé et on a démontré qu'on
pouvait retarder la progression de la
maladie les métastases
la progression des métastases mais tout
récemment l'étude démontré qu'en
prolonge de façon significative la
survie de ces gens pour florian jean le
traitement du dr saad a été décisif il
m'appelle en mai reculé une autre étude
démontre qu'un prescrivent un plus
rapidement un traitement on peut faire
des gains importants
c'est extraordinaire ça dépasse toutes
mes attentes personnelles veux juste
commencé plus tôt on améliore tellement
le la sur vie des gens l'utilisation de
technologies de pointe et de radio
trassard permet également de mettre à
jour des cancers de très petite taille
qui était est visible au paravent à ces
patients là oui on qu'un cercle est
relocalisé mons et très bien d'après
leurs caractéristiques sont taris
d'abord de la maladie qui est non
détectées et qui serait néfaste a laissé
une empreinte et dans une étude plus
on a ainsi amélioré la précision du
diagnostic de 50 % des participants
on a eu beaucoup de marques de succès
avec des nouveaux médicaments des
nouvelles approches ne vous ré du
traceur nouvelle imagerie fait que c'est
un moment très très intéressant de
pouvoir participer aux recherches aucun
soin d'apprécier si tout se déroule bien
on souhaite implanter cette nouvelle
façon de diagnostiquer ce cancer de bout
à l'autre du pays
ici normal rondelle radio canada
montréal